we've got another story and we'll we'll
leave with this real quick but um
there's a story out of arkansas about a
guy who stops a mass shooting
and i think it's really important to
talk about because had there
had this man that have been there then
every outlet would be oh no another
tragedy another mass shooting from you
know crazy you know far right white
but he he killed i believe uh one person
and then a guy grabbed his rifle and
stopped him
it's a horrifying horrifying event but i
mean in in life
people do crazy things this can happen
so in in looking up the story and i'll
jump to in a second
i looked up constitutional carry in the
u.s and the funny thing is
we the gun the gun rights advocates have
been winning yeah
like and i mean like winning winning
yeah they
they have this map here and you can see
it's uh uh going through the years
and 1986 vermont that's it i mean in
1986 you almost couldn't get a gun
anywhere
it was may issue across the country
meaning states could be like screw you
you don't get a concealed carry permit
now it's beyond concealed carry it's
straight up many states are without
being constitutional carry
so we have here right like i mean look
at this the blue
that you can see on the screen is shall
issue meaning if you apply for a
concealed carry
they have to give it to you it can be
kind of prohibitively
bureaucratic you're going to get it so
there's only some areas of new
of the you know of the northeast and
california and maryland that are
may issue meaning you can apply and they
can tell you to screw off rude
but all of most of the country now
except for
new jersey long island and hawaii those
are
no issue in practice they call it
meaning you're not getting a gun yeah
but in most of the country you can get a
gun and more importantly
all this green it's like constitutional
carry
yeah you can walk in now texas is about
to do it texas is about to pass
constitutional carry that means you can
walk into a gun shop
you do a background check a lot of i
guess these democrat people don't
understand
you have to do a background check
sometimes they tell you come back in a
week sorry
sometimes they say you're being
researched it'll take 15 20 minutes
sometimes they say they've cleared you
but after your background check is done
they you can buy your gun and then in
these constitutional carry states you
can walk out the door with it yeah
tennessee as well they're doing the same
thing
yeah they're they they are now it's like
it's it's brought across the country and
that's because
they had i mean the nra was part of it
but gun owners of america and these
organizations on the activists had
one vision and it was i'm gonna buy be
able to buy a gun wherever i want to and
they have been successful it is
you know not every vision is this grand
scheme but the
right had that on on guns and they don't
have it on a large scoop thing and so
i'll tell you one of one of the visions
that i've certainly been having over the
past year this is a story from
bearingarms.com
armed citizen uses rifle to stop
attempted mass shooting
now for the most part i told everyone
the story already they say it was an 87
year old woman
there was a guy who was yelling at
people get out here come out here
everyone go to the building right now
when an older woman went out to uh two
women went out
to console him they saw that he had a
weapon they fled
he went into the apartments of one of
the women and he took her life
at some point there was a neighbor who
grabbed a rifle of his
own and fatally shot the the killer the
police haven't
released many details of the incident we
don't know yet what motivated arnold to
kill his elderly neighbor
it's clear that as a resident amber lane
told local media there could have been
many more victims were
not for the quick response by the armed
citizen here's what happens
the democrat types and i say this
specifically because leftists like
actual socialists they love guns
they want guns they want to revolution
so they advocate for guns karl marx said
keep your guns so these democrat
establishment types these elites are
like no one should have guns but the
police oh by the way defund the police
sure whatever i digress
they they want to take away the weapons
from the people then a criminal will get
a gun
commit a mass tragedy and they'll say
see this is exactly why we're saying
take away your guns
they'll make gun laws more restrictive
which will make the problem continually
worse
and keep using the problem they created
to justify
making the problem worse so in my vision
people have a right to keep and bear
arms and when unfortunate situations
happen people have right to defend
themselves
that's what i see a department of gun
services where when you turn 16 you go
in
you fill out the paperwork they bring
you to the range you do a standard
shooting test and then you get your free
government issued
ar or handgun i'm somewhat kidding
but the point is i'm saying i think
people should be
uh trained should understand gun safety
from a young age
and should keep and bear arms don't they
do that in switzerland like you have to
have a gun in the household
they say that and we talked about that
yesterday i'm not sure how true that is
okay
it's like i think i think it's an urban
legend okay that's partially true
so yeah yeah in switzerland i don't
think it is required but it is very
commonly accepted that you will be
practicing shooting
young people do it they used to have
like a boys shooting club obviously now
they take
girls and everything but they train them
they teach them to use it as a tool this
is something that i was arguing about
it's like this is something that you
need to respect
but it also needs to be culturally
accepted that you're going to have a gun
it shouldn't be weird they did it after
world war ii right or during world war
ii so they armed everybody so if the
nazis ever invaded everyone had a
firearm
i think i don't know maybe i'm i'm wrong
but and and and i know
people who listen to this show are going
back on tim's bring up the same argument
again but uh because you have you maybe
have not heard it my argument is like
you know people drive cars
and i don't think they're gonna hit me
with their car sometimes people hit
people with cars sometimes on purpose
but uh i feel totally comfortable with
everybody being armed so long as
they understand actually i feel much
safer with them understanding gun safety
and having a well look how many people
actually have guns and look how
relatively few murders there are and
look at me i mean bill of cars and i'm
relatively you know minor accidents
there are but people are on their
smartphones like playing video game
texting while walking our street is
amazing that aren't like thousands of
bodies scattered across major leagues
but it does happen like people generally
are you know and there are some people
who are
off their rock or like the vegas shooter
or whoever who like want to commit
horrible acts well we don't know enough
about that guy actually so okay
so whatever the columbine kids whatever
the case is there are people who do want
to create
terrible situations and um and
they do exist but they're always going
to exist i mean that crazy people do
crazy things yeah absolutely
the argument from the left is that
because there is a small fraction of
crazy people
the overwhelming majority 99.999
shouldn't be able to find themselves
that makes
no sense you know who they're looking
for you know the lieutenant governor of
north carolina as
have you heard of this guy he's uh rob
robinson is his last name i can remember
his first time he gave a speech they
were trying to do gun control
in his local county and he gave a speech
it went viral
mark robinson saying that you know your
your criticisms of of
people committing crimes always how do
we hurt the law how we how do we hurt
the people
you know abiding by the law he's a big
black man rural place has a big rural
accent
and uh great great great man and he's
like i am the majority because majority
are law abiding gun owners
not i'm not a minority and this is the
problem is you say how do i hurt the
majority immediately not not ever go
after the minority none of these things
these laws they propose
hurts the criminals yeah it's it's like
well we're gonna make it worse for
people who actually obey the law
yeah and until we end up with like the
minority port where you can sit there
and go into the future it's not gonna
it's not gonna change a good point that
was brought up by our guest yesterday
forest cooper was that suppressors for
instance make
firing rifles safer those get banned
because
people have no idea what they're talking
about or they get restricted under
the nfa yeah and the problem is with the
media is and i worked i used to work at
the washington examiner
you know many a few years ago like five
years ago and um
most people and that was the right way
media people don't own guns in the media
especially
like new york media dc media yeah they
don't own guns they never fire them
wasn't like the washington post who had
a picture of like a chainsaw attached to
a machine gun or they always use it
today
it was like literally a chainsaw next to
it like
that yeah it was it was the most insane
thing ever like clearly a
a weapon that would never ever work it
was like a star wars
and this was a serious like combination
of possibly deadly weapons that they you
know people could have
we got it we got it we gotta look at
this november 8th 2017 usa today issues
clarification after depicting rifle with
a chainsaw fan oh my god
i gotta say i'm just i love this the guy
i can't remember which news outlet he
worked for maybe it's washington post
he said firing an ar-15 gave him a
temporary form of ptsd and get the hell
out of here
get the hell out of here dude i could i
always say this imagine if the guy maybe
if you're a bad shot
like it would be you'd be humiliated by
it but ptsd is
i i as as i've you know gotten more
heavily involved in you know gun
ownership
experienced firing at 12 gauge and
firing an ar with five you know in five
five six
and if this guy thinks that the the 556
was
was giving was that bad i and that's
that's the actual weapon of war
556 nato then i couldn't imagine him
going small game hunting
yeah he'd be like oh my arm it hurts
what's happening i actually find
i find smaller guns i don't like
handguns at all because it doesn't feel
real like i don't feel like i feel like
i'm shooting
with a gun when i'm shooting a rifle
when i'm shooting at a handgun i'm like
this feels like a toy like i really
don't this doesn't feel safe like i feel
like i would like accidentally blow my
head off but like a rifle you have some
kind of command of it
and if yeah if he had that i mean that's
a lot that's uh
that's the man who cries after sex
there's
no way he doesn't there's like validity
to uh
loud explosions and noises causing like
long-term stress they call it shell
shock after world war one for people in
the trenches but
yeah but i think as a human you really
that was our artillery shell like coming
next time
for months for months at a time right we
have a duty as humans to
to to learn how to handle large
explosions
like we should just be able to deal with
that well i said a car bomb went off
next to him it was shooting a gun once
with an instructor safety gear on people
do demolition
like for a living across the whole
country and never have this
the myth busters would blow stuff up
every day and
you know in the mojave desert for fun
for a tv show the whole earth
rocks when they're demolishing a giant
skyrise and you're like six blocks away
that's that's
bro we we knocked down a tree in my
backyard when we were in the philly area
we had to get a tree move because it was
dying and it was like out of fungus or
something
and so they're like what we're going to
do is we're going to go up they climb to
the top
they cut chunks of the top off then
measure and they say okay we're going to
knock it down straight this way it's
going to slam into the ground
though it was like an earthquake it was
crazy when that massive tree came down i
did not realize
the like shake that you would feel was
like whoa
it was like an explosion it was crazy
and then we had someone across the
street the same thing and one day i'm
sitting there like boom the whole house
chicks i'm like
wow this guy couldn't handle firing a
gun yeah
and there's a there's a photo of a
little girl i love the little girl with
the pink
you know yeah but uh i i i've been to
a bunch of different places around
around the world with civil unrest and
conflict
and i've been in a bunch of riots and
there was one point where i was in new
york
i was walking down broadway in brooklyn
and a car backfired
and then i immediately got an adrenaline
rush it was like whoa
because i was so used to being on the
ground in these conflict situations that
when the bang went off it was like
that's when you were like in action mode
and then i was like kind of laughing at
myself i was like wow man
it's like i gotta chill out i guess
cause i'm getting yeah but like i mean
there are people who like live in like
syria during the revolution and like
they
undergo horrible things on a daily basis
and they don't sit there and feel the
need to write an op-ed about how they
were emotionally triggered by
every moment of their life they just you
know you move on it's a shotgun you shot
once
if you watch videos from these war zones
many of them in more urban areas you
will see people literally just doing
their daily business
right you'll hear gunshots and see a guy
like just walking carrying like a
basketball
well that was old new york new york i
mean i grew up there my whole life i'm a
8th generation new yorker it
makes you tough if you live there your
whole life and you just are unfazed by
certain things there was like a failed
bombing there a couple of years ago and
like
and like the press ran there and there
are people like they're like can you
stop like no i'm on my way to work what
are you talking about yeah so
it just happened like i'm on my work
right that that's what it makes you and
i guess
if you're a very fragile person who's
been very comfortable your entire life
like the most minimal thing just as
there and shakes you
i think more than that he had an agenda
to push to them oh of course yeah and i
was reading about switzerland and far
from being a response to world war ii
the reason that germany did not invade
switzerland was because every man has to
be in the military and yes they do have
guns in every single home they're issued
by the government which is stems
there's a there's a town the next
right-wing president him is the head of
the department of gun ownership
gun services there's a town in georgia
that mandates gun ownership kennesaw oh
really
yeah yeah oh wow i know that that's it
oh yeah mandates i want to go there
this is this way do you get to pick your
gun out or does it say
you have to own one but you how do they
give you one okay but you don't they
don't sit there and say it has to be
this style of gun you could say any gun
oh i don't know i got it that's
interesting if they say like you know
it's like north korea if that's
certainly not a hairstyle but they're
certain
that's why i'm wondering so there's like
five to choose i think i think at the
department of gun services they would
have like you know
two rifles to choose from and like two
different handguns yeah and then just
but you know they're going to be like
garbage government issue yeah you don't
want that yeah
like soviet union stuff like the 60s i'm
like yeah yeah government cheese
you walk in they're like we've got a
captured ak you know
you got to use it the whole thing falls
apart it's like exactly
that's smart it's free with our tracking
mechanisms and you have to
turn in you're going to get a new 2023
smart gun
i like to listen to your talking i think
i think it'll be a great equalizer to
give everybody access
but now look the rich people will have
the really great of course high tech
stuff
but then the people the regular people
can be able to walk in and you know get
a handgun but you know what you were
mentioning before the box of ammo too we
were talking before about like policing
and everything like that
and the defunded police is coming out of
a lot of the woke labs and especially
the wealthy left who live in private
gated communities
a big thing about the police that people
don't understand is it's not only
something about social about safety it's
about
climbing up the economic ladder my
family my dad said super poor 11 kids
super irish catholic every boy became a
cop because that's your only avenue to
join the middle class
if you cut off that avenue now in every
major city in this country basically
uh policemen are majority minority most
are non-white
you is the avenue to become part of the
middle class for people who have no
other way of going to college and
spending 40 000 years and doing it
by cutting off the ability to become a
cop because the alternative now is to
become a sociologist and you know back
up 200 grand in debt
by cutting off the ability to be part of
the middle class
the alternative for social security for
these gated communities is going to be
uh private security guards without a
pension probably making maybe 25
an hour and that's it with no ability to
retire it keeps it actually suppresses
people
poor people even more both in urban
communities are making them less safe
but also cutting off the opportunity to
join the middle class
i know that's a totally random thing but
the riots are the same thing they
destroy
residential neighborhoods they destroy
businesses and the ultra wealthy can buy
up cheap property and then sit down and
wait until the product but if you care
if you're supposed to be a working class
people this
this is what you're supposed to actually
care about is how does the work in class
how does the working poor
make it in this country and and and
advance themselves to some
not everyone's gonna be a billionaire
and not everyone needs to be a
billionaire or a millionaire but
some level some floor of comfortability
where you know their kids will do better
themselves and they'll have some
respectability at the end of their life
if that's the end goal as it should be
for any socio-economic policy
this does the complete opposite yes it
destroys
property but it also cuts off the path
to middle class thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time